What do
you want me to do? I think you know that demons are increasing in Kyoto, but
white is the cause of the resurrection of the demon god.
Cooperate with you to get the incense I
have no use for anything other than goblins I
understand that the army and police are coming in. I understand that the fate of the world is gathering I
can understand, but before the world is destroyed  The goblins destroy the village, and the
world's crisis will be a reason to miss
the goblins.  If that's the
case, where did you get it?--
The size of the shamans that should have been confirmed,
and this guy
is
exactly as my companion said
.  The Chiefs of the Human Race
A lot of elves and dwarves gather to hold a conference
.  It means that the movement of the ice in that chapter has become active over the
years
.  By the way, we found a big
burrow. We can't move our army against goblins.
I'm divorced from a hut, but
it's Sora So, even if I thought it was Hume
Oroku Bolger Why did you get singled out
? Is there a map?
You can decide what you like, so
this guy goes alone, wrapped